hambach dieses spiels überzeugt mich
jedes mal aufs neue look at that as we
were amazing herzlich willkommen zum
golfsimulator meine damen und herren ich
bin diese ziele und wir haben gerade
unseren staat kaputt gemacht viele haben
sich mal wieder gewünscht deswegen hab
ich mir gedacht ich habe diese frau
gerade getötet was macht der typ da
hinten
das hat weh getan
ich verstehe gar nichts fragt mich nicht
was was hier gerade abläuft freunde ich
meinen po ist an seinem po zu stecken
kamel die spiele hier die pay day
dingsbums das heißt ich glaube ich kann
so dünn war es ist ein delfin aber gut
luca als goalgetter nicht kennt es geht
darum dass ich einfach was worum geht es
eigentlich in diesem spiel ich bin ein
delfin der aus einem rollstuhl sitzt und
mit seinen flossen an schwung nimmt ich
glaube ich muss nicht mehr viel dazu
sagen außer dass ich jetzt diesen mann
weg
warum
es macht keinen sinn ist sie manchmal
frage ich mich ob mein ganzes leben
überhaupt einen sinn hat ob ich das
richtige tue aber dann sehe ich mir halt
diese frau an
und irgendwie hat mein leben dann doch
einen tieferen sind durch dir helfen das
du dagegen wie weg kommst hab ich doch
gern gemacht jetzt ist da der nächste
spaß die der irgendwo gegen läuft schon
wollt ihr mich denn alle verarschen muss
ich hier die welt retten oder was was
geht denn ab alle liegen einfach dumm
hey ich kann mein ganzes video damit
füllen wir diese spaß dies auf
irgendeinem holzkisten dinge laufen wir
schauen mal was es sonst noch für
menschen gibt die mich haben wir hier
vorne eine person die ich weiß echt
nicht was ich davon halten soll ich
finds auch stark dass der delfin auf dem
rollstuhl schneller ist als ein
fahrendes auto aber schaut mal wir
können einfach einen delfin der im
rollstuhl sitzt fährt gegenden auto
fliegt aus seinem rollstuhl
wollt ihr mich für alle fakten in diesem
spiel was ist das hier
wie hoch kann ich dann eigentlich gehen
will es jetzt wissen müssen leute
natürlich ich bin so hoch wie ein
hochhaus und er dreht trotzdem noch
seine datsche füßchen um voranzukommen
ich frag mich ehrlich gesagt was
passiert wenn ich jetzt hier gegen diese
brücke gegen fahre deshalb okay es in
ordnung könnte ich nicht theoretisch
jetzt über dieses ding auf was geht
eigentlich da hinten ab ich häng hier
irgendwie mit meinem rollstuhl an der
wand und dahinten passierten mega
autounfall und zwei autos liegen
übereinander und jetzt fährt noch ein
anderes auto rein wahrscheinlich ja auch
was ich verstehe gar nichts mehr leute
ich kann die wand von dem hochhaus
hochfahren mit so einem ding leute und
jetzt bin ich auf dem hochhaus was
passiert die wir sind jetzt ein kamel
meine damen und herren das heißt ich
warum fallen alle menschen in meiner
gegenwart um warum es geht hier ab
ist ja auch komplett egal was hier alles
passiert ich meine das einzige ziel was
ich habe ist irgendwie mit diesem kamel
ein toller da läufst du nichts ahnend
durch die stadt mit einem kamel und dann
ist da oben einfach der delfin das kamel
fährt ein auto also ich meine es ist
nicht so dass dem spiel schon jeglicher
bezug zur realität fehlt aber jetzt
sitzt auch noch ein kamel in dem auto
ich weiß nicht was passiert wenn ich in
diesem tunnel rennfahrer ob ich dann in
eine andere welt
oder ich der tunnel ist gar kein
wirklicher tunnel ich bin jetzt mal eben
zum letzten charakter geschwitzt und
zwar einem pelikan oder einen flamingo
mit dem ich jetzt hier einfach mal hoch
fliege und ich wollte nämlich schon
immer mal schauen was hier oben
eigentlich ab g8 war dieses furzkissen
haben nach diesem spiel zu überzeugt
mich jedes mal aufs neue
ich sehe da spiele ich einmal wieder
gautschi later und irgendwie bin ich mit
einem kamel einem auto gefahren hier
vorne ist mein delfin immer noch in
seinem komischen rollstuhl aber zu guter
letzt starten wir jetzt nochmal den
menschen von beginn des videos einen
kleinen besucher er läuft immer noch die
box hoch und runter es hat sich nichts
verändert
das was ihr von mir meine damen und
herren ich hatte einfach mal wieder bock
kilometer hoch zu laden euch gefallen
hat und dem er wollte dass man leichter
und 200.000 likes verlose ich euch diese
wasserflasche hier findet ihr zwei
angemeldet wenn ihr darauf könnt ihr
main kanal abonnieren es ist wie es ist
kostenlos und frei und kostenlos
bedeutet eigentlich das gleiche und hier
findet ihr irgendein anderes video
eingeblendet also wenn ihr bock habt
noch ein anderes video von mir
anzuschauen dann schaut euch an
michael hamm
live